let's just start joining us good morning
how are you hi this is so exciting to be
here what do you think of this man kid
uh well I've been to the one in New York
yeah that was a long time ago
that's different very yeah we got a lot
of toys here that's like a loft
apartment in New York right okay
this is an airplane this is huge yes
yeah so you can show me around after
maybe I'll give you a tour okay yeah be
nice last time I I joined the show I I
think you had me cooking yeah you cooked
eggs I breakfast first yeah it was great
but you brought a friend who could cook
oh no she was just my she was my sous
chef sous chef kids I can cook oh oh
well we have video of it oh yeah there
you are cooking see who liked it I liked
it I didn't need him that was there I
helped that a little bit I was like
stirring something I don't great time
she checks me she goes should I bring
eggs and I go no I'm not gonna make you
I was reminded of this because the game
was in Mexico City last night of course
Melissa used to do sideline for ABC that
was Al Michaels was there with John
Madden and Dennis Miller well no first
it was Dan fat it was Dan Fouts that was
with dollar okay and Al and Eric
Dickerson that was the first group when
we took over in 2000 we were a team of
five yeah so uh and then it was John
Madden and Al Michaels and me okay so
yeah the game the Mexico City game I do
and I don't read Wikipedia but Wikipedia
suggests the following in 2001 Melissa
stark was detained in Mexico after a
security guard not knowing she worked
for ABC covering an NFL game refused her
Al Michaels Dan Fouts entry to the
stadium the detention lasted a while
before the matter was resolved charges
were dropped
stark admits to being quite embarrassed
that she couldn't communicate with
Mexican police since Spanish will
one of her making sure true parts of it
are true wait you weren't to take I
can't I mean I was not detained
I was never arrested I don't know
anything about that part it Wikipedia
also says i'm 5-4 so you're 5-2 so in
Kyler's marie know what bothers you more
than here listen 5-4 or you were
detained in Mexico maybe the five
because everybody was wondering how tall
Kyler I was taller than 80 wasn't heels
I was not detained um but but I don't
speak great Spanish so let's not but
that was a manager it was a minor it was
a minor I think there's a minor but when
you if you don't use it you know that I
mean I don't know if you speak another
[Laughter]
[Music]
working on this one get my under that
was that that was good memories of going
back to Mexico City with a with that
crew what's your favorite Monday night
story because you're with legends
they're doing the Monday night games
right is there one that stands out well
we had a couple of that first season
that we did was it was in 2000 and for
some reason all the games I mean
literally all the games came down to the
wire we had the the longest game in
Monday Night Football history that was
the Vinny Testaverde yeah and I just
remember we had some funny stories
because we had Don ohlmeyer the old
producer that you know started it in the
70s and he was a legend in the business
but you know it was it was it was great
it was great um
the Antonio Freeman catch we had that
one I mean we just had some we had some
really awesome games but I do remember
my first one my second game ever doing
the sidelines so you know you're I was
nervous I was young that was 26 years
old I was out there and they wanted me
to stand like as close as I could to the
pirate no no and my sweater caught on
fire deferring during the live shot I
mean during it I mean it was awful it
was
I got through it you know what I got
through I don't know if you saw this but
I was hit in the head with a football in
London I heard about that yeah so I had
not done
I returned to the sidelines in London
doing these international games on NFL
Network and I hadn't done it in 15 years
and the best was the makeup artist was
standing there and she didn't know
anything about American football so she
kept flinching every time the footballs
came near so I said don't work and boom
I was hit by a football so I've got a
lot of good experiences on the sideline
were you in concussion protocol after
then you know what I was not I was um I
was not actually luckily I thought about
how it could have actually been really
bad but it hit kind of hit my shoulder
and looked looked looked worse than when
it's alive you gotta just I just kept
going I just kept talking to the best
was I was talking I knew they weren't
listening to a word I was taking it was
to do because they were laughing so hard
who threw it no it was Brett current it
was a no it was a punt oh so it was
bouncing up yeah the guys in London
didn't necessarily know how to like you
know handle them the guys that were
shagging them are you how often did you
hear things on the sidelines where you
can't say what you're hearing even
though it would be good content right
like who judges what you can and can't
say you're kind of like referring back
to the Odell Beckham thing from us like
from last week or just things you over
here yeah yeah
so you judge it right you you don't have
to buy somebody no no okay Beckham stuff
right right explain like you mean no I
was saying a couple of weeks ago it was
reported he said you know I can't catch
the yeah I can't catch the ball was it
my life yeah so I was just know that
that's all I was saying was when do you
pick and choose what you say but that's
on the record though wasn't that picked
up or was it somebody who heard it the
sideline reporter overheard it okay and
was criticized for saying it okay yep
what you'll have reported that I know I
thought about that I mean I might have I
just think I would have yeah everything
is fair game now with microphones and
and we keep bringing the viewer closer
right where it's kind of hard to the
lines are blurred of what what can I say
and not say was something
like that a lot of play he might have he
might have overheard him saying that
passing a lot of times players will say
something to me they're probably not
supposed to talk to you but say
something to me directly and I always
you know report that but the PR staffs
they're still they try and keep you as
far away as possible you know they
always say you can't stand right here
move aside or you know that type of
thing but like an injury you know that's
where you have to kind of rely on
somebody to give you that information
yes - and they can decide what they want
to give you or not give you yes and some
teams are better than others were you
ever run over on the sidelines run over
by a player yeah no no no that's good no
I get out of the way yeah but there
would be times if you could be looking
one way and then all of a sudden you
could get hit right I mean the
photographer got hit last week on the
sidelines of a game yeah who said a
college game right where you just
looking the other way
that never happened monthly just the
football hitting me in the head right
I've always been fascinated with Pat
Tillman and I saw snippets of this the
Tillman scholars and just how you know
these these men and the military women
in the military they benefited from Pat
Tillman they talked about him they did
know Pat Tillman but just that legacy
they're how powerful and I remember
lobbying the NFL when Pat died single
out the 42 yard line in every NFL
stadium because you should have this as
a a learning moment not a teaching but a
learning so if your son or daughter goes
why do they have the 42 yard line so you
don't forget people like this and of
course it fell on deaf ears with the NFL
because they're like well if you do it
for Pat Tillman I go how many guys are
gonna leave football team I yes yeah
what did you find out about Pat so so I
too have always been fascinated by his
story I mean I have a lot of like a lot
of my family members have served in the
military and so that's where it
resonates with me also I I met him when
I was covered when I was working for The
Today Show and so and I remember I was I
was anchoring the early Today Show and
had a report on his death and it was
just I mean everything about him
resonated with me and all of us who
cover sports and we call these NFL
players heroes and then you look at like
what a true unbelievable hero he is so
so
I mean here's what we know so this is 15
years after his death so here's what we
know about pat tillman obviously that he
rose to NFL star at him and that he
walked away from this multi-million
dollar contract to become an Army Ranger
and then of course he died on the
battlefield in Afghanistan but so what
they this is like this Pete what we did
tonight this show so NFL 360 is sort of
like the past the best of the best and
the pieces that we can work on literally
been working on this for a year and when
went to Fort Benning and we're with the
75th Ranger Regiment and just to act the
video and everything that we have in
here is amazing so we talked to a master
sergeant who served with Pat and talks
about how they all reacted the day that
they learned that he died and and I
think what this really is tonight like
you were talking about 15 years later
living that he lives on through all
these Tillman scholars so they're the
Tillman foundation was born because
after he died
people started they said they started
sending in checks to the Arizona
Cardinals like $5 $50 100 whatever
saying I don't care what you do with it
just do something in his name and so
they founded this Tillman foundation and
so the Tillman scholars are there's six
hundred and thirty five of them and they
add 50 to 60 each year and they're the
they're our future leaders like they're
the best of the best the brightest minds
so biochemists they're all basically
they're all service members or veterans
or their spouses and the Tillman
Foundation funds like their service to
our country in a new area of pursuit and
or a new field of study so they're
Harvard Law graduates they're they're
NASA astronauts but that the Toman
foundation has helped them get there so
what do you think Pat would be doing now
I know it's interesting because Adrian
Perkins who I went to Luke fort
Louisiana and he's one of the Tillman
scholars and I went to he's the mayor of
Louisiana and he says I think he went
back to do this and he he was a West
Point graduate he was the first
african-american president in in the
history of West Point he was a cadet
there he went to Harvard Law School and
he was the president there the student
body president but turned out all the
major
Law Firm offers all the big money to go
back and be the mayor of his hometown
which he needed so much Shreveport
Louisiana yeah police reform in criminal
justice and all that he says I think
every day what Pat would be doing and he
thought he'd be in politic you know he'd
be doing something that made a
difference in terms of politics and so
he feel so this guy Adrian Perkins who I
think will be President one day feels
like he's living the way Pat would all
these Solman scholars never met the man
right but they're trying to make him
proud and they're trying to live this
life and and service over sacrifice over
sir excuse me they're sacrificing over
self is what I mean to say but you look
back on this and what man does this
where you have a successful career and
you see you have a family a new wife
9/11 happens yeah
what did you ever you know maybe it's
not fair to ask you this but do you did
anybody say like what triggered cuz
that's that's not something you just go
I'm going to war I'm going now I'm
giving this all up right what was that
characteristic your gene that he had
right I mean not many people have it I I
don't know because I don't know him
personally so I don't know exactly what
that was but I think he felt in in in a
way to sum it up like he felt it was
immoral not to serve not to serve I mean
he felt that compelled and that much of
a conviction but what did his wife say
like that conversation I can't imagine
you come home and go or maybe he's
watching 9/11 and and I a new contract
new wife right I'm going I'm going into
the military
right it's interesting you say that
because one of the things that you'll
see tonight in this piece is a lot of
these guys grapple with the fact they
can I can I take my family through this
like can I can I put this on them
because this is and Schulten Marie
Tillman would tell you he didn't that
didn't think this was a sacrifice he
didn't look at as a sacrifice he looked
at it as kind of his duty and his
obligation so a different breed
but but what's great and he's not the
only person who did this but he had this
high profile job and you know we do
we're not used to and as you said we
tend to say you're a warrior as you know
somebody in a sporting event you're not
you know that warrior is somebody who is
in war and not somebody who's playing
football right Pat was he played the
game as a warrior but he was a true
warrior by going over there and fighting
for our country there but and other
people made that sacrifice but he gave
up something gave up a lot to go over
there but I'm not sure he looked at it
that way I don't think he looked at it
that way and friendly fire that you get
killed right and just that and even
talking to his wife about that I mean
not that there's any scenario where you
go okay I'm okay with this or this is
better than another but the fact that he
was killed right and you'll see tonight
in the show the master sergeant who
talks about it when they found that out
when they that's just and you could see
the emotion and the it's just so raw and
so real even 15 years later for them to
even talk about I'm glad you came up
well thanks I'm so glad you had me you
got heels on so you can't shoot hoops
with us but I have sneakers so I can
change sneakers yes if we want to is
that something that you do we do we put
on I put on a shooting clinic usually
every day okay and it's free you've got
boys I'd be more than happy to put on a
shooting clinic I should bring them up
well your husband's a football player so
I should be able to a former one so I
should be able to help out your kids if
they want to play basketball that's
great okay more than happy not to
mention your daughters if they want to
play too but one of mine just brutally
broke her leg playing soccer and is in a
cast up to her hip it was sort of a like
she a side tackle by the goalie and yeah
really bad do you want to mention the
goalies name and I got some people I
know and you're gotten sooner all right
tune in tonight NFL 360 the legacy of
Pat Tillman and this will be an 8:00
Eastern on NFL Network it's uh this
story is written by the Tillman scholars
who fifteen years after his death are
changing the world in his
you can catch the uncor - an event FL
network following Thursday Night
Football as well for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]